hello hello hi who are you Susan Susan
hello Susan where are you from Susan I
just moved to London from Virginia did
you move here for love or verge all my
love my husband Oh was he British no I'm
actually British I got my citizenship
last year through my mom oh well done
you Susan she's British I was working as
a detox therapist I was massaging my
clients feet with essential oils you
found the right sofa for this with this
story one of her feet had quite a bit of
hair on the top of it she had an injury
and had to get two skin grafts so they
took the skin graft from her pubic area
the skin started growing back pubic hair
on top of her Wow she was telling me
this very nonchalantly oh now my friends
call me [__] food haha
I'm gonna be massaging someone's pubic
hair I want the choice I don't want it
sprung on me like out of the blue has
some surprise so I didn't find it very
funny you and everybody but it was a
very point thank you for you are massage
therapists you massage someone's [__]
whether it's on there
[Applause]
it's not what I said
No
[Applause]
hello sir good eye oh it is interesting
no one who actually is from here wants
to do this it's like does this go
towards getting your green card inside
the red chair on
why doesn't we do what's your name sir
Simon waiting from Sydney and do you
live here now
I do I do you even work it out yes I'm a
lawyer Wow he works in a bar
okay mark I'll seal the destroy okay so
I used to be in the Navy and about 14
years ago 14 years ago I was driving a
ship through the South China Sea with
that piloting it really in the Navy
during my ship through
okay will believe you off you go okay
they're in the South China Sea and I
look at calls over and said there's
something in the water about a hundred
yards off the port beam so we go out and
have a look and dead-set as real as I'm
sitting here now
there was a mermaid in the water that
was going to be a really lame joke
maybe he was just saying he wasn't
really sitting there maybe you're
flicking reality that maybe were in the
matrix okay one more let's see if we
listed is saying Nina
sorry Nina Nina yes like an ambulance
very good Magister yeah
finally you keep rally what's going
decent brave person
you know turning British story
coughing a red chair by an Irishman Nina
sorry to hold you this story see I moved
to Spain and I was really keen on
learning the lingo and obviously the
first colleague started to give me words
of the day so one day my word of the day
was chicken so we go to the supermarket
I'm very confident in our doing chicken
I give my order to the butcher everyone
starts to laugh around me and I'm like
why you laughing my friend next time is
rolling around on the floor laughing and
he told me I've got the word chicken
confused with the word penis
[Applause]
Gold out there but we have matter you
come on come on
hello sir okay the hopes of a nation
Iran you Paul yes and were you from I'm
from Colchester Essex gorgeous on Essex
and what do you do there well I've been
working Colchester working Thompson but
I work in retail
was in the details
is the bridge of the Starship Enterprise
see he doesn't have a sort of William
Shatner thing going on
[Applause]
this story I was working on what was a
fairly short construction job at the
local zoo oh and John Picard is talking
on a fairly hazy morning I was holding
up a steel which didn't manage to keep
hold of and it slipped from my fingers
and as it did it went across the road
that was into the ring-tailed lemur
enclosure but actually snapped through
the electric fence and jam in the corner
of the in the corner of the the pit that
I was working in and actually the
electric fence was on quite high and
where I'd got jammed it actually come up
between my legs and I'd actually got
electric shock for a couple of minutes
before could actually moved whereby all
the ring-tailed lemurs have actually
decided to escape
[Applause]
[Music]
dear David Walliams I love your books
but I got one book wasn't very good book
was building netball I trim there leads
to youth and the more